you
all righty
we have a good crowd 45 at the start of
this one
the ultimate sh s l gamer is in there
let's see if I get paired with them
yupper okay throwing some different
lines at me and our first three games
let's get a pin in there hmm
okay ask a question first
and
and go here I'm try for this Bishop on
b7 they're allowing and we'll run it
like this okay how about a dark square
Bishop exchange we get that oh yeah I
think he's just too good a five a four
okay with a queen trade still push on
with this okay with a Queen trade let's
just uh let's play around a little bit
just a little bit shut down that
diagonal hmm
maybe a night here that seemed
pretty sweet sometime wreck trapped
wheeze trapped love it bishop in let's
offer a queen trade and i guess we go
here huh let's come back over don't like
how applying this my
oh my goodness my time my time man
honest getting broken down to Bishop
takes pawn bishop
spawn yeah going for more and why not
ah man
tournament they were flying
flying
ah man my recon a1 was stupid they had
good coordination mm okay we got to get
back on the horse as always try to get a
four unlike the last tournament this guy
gonna move he's movin I had a good
structure with that one I was happy with
the position but I was not playing fast
enough okay
maybe push once pink get off first and
I'll do this
maybe we'll shoot for an f4 mo I have
this covered enough let's defend my
queen as it can to play
the weakens before let's get the brook
here h 3 and then f 4 now this wins a
night they're going to stir up some
trouble though let's see how I don't
think there could be too much trouble
takes 994 they resigns hmm ok
that was a pretty quick one maybe that
first loss wasn't so bad standings wise
23 minutes left 30 first place jjd chess
stride d4
so Indiana the bishop pair let's get
these guys running and allow me to pin
that night huh let's counsel keep that
pin hmm castled yet King side I don't
know if I want to really take that night
just yet um let's keep the tension I
know I could have just capped okay now
we're definitely doing this and I was
always tempted to maybe take with the
rook first and have a bishop knifing
into the position Queen takes h6 as a
threat
where's the mate hook up and over that
should do the trick
Bishop G
or I guess incoming Bishop g4 gonna have
to give up the Queen soon oh I had this
and then here okay I have that right now
instead of h3 Queen g5 rook h6 would do
the trick
let's just take incoming [ __ ] [ __ ] man
come on get that me you know you want to
get that made somehow we've a mate
we got four we got fire maybe I get a
four
come on I need a for mr. kid is in
eleventh who's in first the gamer he
preserved his game after me Manny Manny
is in second the door book first time
playing now second time playing alright
now the Queen has to come out and now
run away scared run away scared okay is
in the think tank he's in the
think-tank oh he's really in the think
tank I love it the door book is thinking
this one through it's an important
moment move seven is always a very
important moment in a game stake don't
know why I said that being silly as
usual low taking with the king
let's get them are you really going to
take that pon h7 discover check finish
development they moved
see that they moved oh that's a problem
vision here
all right dropping my queen should not
be an issue
tonight right here all right we're
pushing through now going to resign
lying on to the to the very end slop up
these pawns
vacuum them up here and then there's me
back determine okay I'm on page one I
got a 4
1310 okay mr. kit
time to read off the numbers we got
another game here a Kings Indian defense
huh Space Invader on d5 let's see how
you deal with that clamp down on d5 I'm
up a pond let's grab that guy develop
flight square I guess here get out of
there clean
shoo
slow you're going to try to repeat let's
try this
oh my goodness why did I do that oh man
I need a phone a friend this is terrible
terrible drop your beep on who needs
them who needs the B bond who needs a
beep on unbelievable
holy cow Bishop f4 who does that raise
your hand I'm raising my hand right now
Forks maybe I got the piece back hang on
no because he's protected oh he he
returned it yes I might have pigs what
day give me the pigs Ron pawn hang on to
that piece he's important oh man
ugliness ugly city man ugly city ah can
you do it can you light square bishop
play an important role
I wonder let's find out come on your
tumors away do something dangerous oh
not so easily they found a way to
coordinate and in the end this is coming
down to rat race unbelievable
I never want to see this game again
Bishop to f4 move of the century Knight
h5 let me put my bishop on f4 because
your Knight isn't hanging up that square
or anything holy cow no more shoes on
is a is on I don't know what I want to
say
he's my opponent English and stuff
English is very difficult
oh boy stay tuned there's got to be some
more wacky moves right around the corner
after playing like that when the d6 pawn
right I'd be on the night at the end
just in case let's get this rook here
how about we go for a dark square bishop
exchange can we try that I'm on a drive
careful Queen look at the sneakiness
fish it takes h6 so sneaky so sneaky
throw a jab at the Queen are we going to
play d5 we are got to get that break in
the knight suits well here I think this
is pretty good defender chop wound
what's the story here let's find out um
I nearly just dropped my queen I was
going to take here King here I don't
have much time
why does it have to
this difficult why am i making life so
difficult for me holy cow
in trouble on the big trouble
Oh Quinn check rook check am I getting
mated no don't hurt me don't hurt me
give me the Queen give me the rook give
me the bishop come on
it's a dangerous night run pawn get a
touchdown kill that night holy cow I
don't know what to think Oh less than 15
all right 16 with fire the gamers in
first he's in a game get a mr. kit 25
2016 miscalculated you know I've seen
this name I've seen this player before
and this is the first time I'm actually
understanding the name miscalculated I
never I'm really slow man I'm really
slow sometimes this is one of those
times get it get it like female and
miscalculated I'm just picking up out
there for the first time oh man
what'd you say okay don't put your
bishop here Knight h5 Bishop f4 amazing
okay I guess I'll repair the f5 square
go after d6 how's that defended bishop
f8 look to e1 f4 nope where's the fork
where is it
can I sneak away with that capture sneak
away watch out for those sneak away
moves okay let's just throw in the check
and then push my pawn I'm going to grab
both my Knights I could take that
actually I have two pieces on it I'm on
the rook yep I am on the rook on the
rook again time edge and they miss that
they miscalculated they miscalculated
Forks down my bishop let's take the
tricky piece and then here just like the
tactics from earlier overloaded pawn get
rid of the rook push the phone keep
pushing they don't have any time back to
tournament where we at third swanny with
fire 29 24 2016 all right
macros in there I guess he started late
only four games in three berserks let's
see we get maybe we get oh he just
finished we're going to get a GM yes we
are okay come on man come on
we played the Karo many times already
many times let's go with this Bishop d6
on Bishop to f4 I'm going to smash
through here
happening soon this may be reinforced it
can I make a move make a move man make a
move any move
I get some trades in let's try for a
bishop trade not happening ship on d6
let's get the knight back to defend a
little bit ah I should probably open my
light square bishop sighs mm-hmm
nikki Finke out of the night hmm
it's scary it's really scary it's extra
scary
uh-huh I thought you might do that I'm
in big trouble I'm down the exchange
down the exchange and down more than
that now ah I'm down a full rook not
good I'll play it out a little bit more
just a hair more not seeing that they're
moving
why I'm losing I'm not seeing that
they're moving not because I'm playing a
terrible game I gave you something Terry
they gave me some material I represent a
beautiful spot okay
hit that resigned button ah man I gotta
go into different variation instead guy
that is not not a good one that a quick
strike at on f7 the main threat I could
take the Queen but then they get me yeah
because my LightSquared bishop I really
want to get him outside the pawn chain
it just doesn't happen in that variation
so I struggle let's break the pin I'm
still in fourth stealing for it
how about Bishop to e3 playing against
Jerri Blank
all right let's crack this open improve
the knight and throw a rook on the same
file of the king
careful now discover checks or do I want
to go snap upon give a check and king g6
now that was their best piece so let's
get rid of them Queen I'll return the
Queen on d5 let's get a flight square
and maybe he attacks a little bit good
double looks as well
Queens unprotected 17 seconds okay it
will pick up the pawn I guess mass
exchanges one King and pawn ending
connected passer they resign back to
turn okay
41 the gamer has not been he's not
slowed down at all 41 27 26 22 I need
fire I need four is 122 in this one gorg
are let's try Sicilian fishing pole
first time I found it maybe they don't
know that I go fishing I'm going to go
clean side looks like they're going
Queen side skiing on the sea
take out queenside this is a this is an
issue
I don't know if I want to give them up
my knife for that Bishop okay now I do
and yeah let's go in a small pond stone
I don't want to see e5 get this rook
working bishop here was a threat
this Knight out of here how can I get my
light square bishop working about a
night here maybe on be three as well
push I could take here okay two bishops
versus two nights
okay I wanted to provoke that all right
maybe here let's trade rooks two nights
I know versus two bishops interesting
two knights versus two bishops okay
which one's my better Bishop this is my
better Bishop now I could win some
material oh I got two pawns now and I'm
on the night and I could track down that
pass fun run run just in case let's
scoot over
three pounds now time edge as well they
resigned back to tournament 4931 26 24
okay I got fire I could maybe sneak into
third here six minutes left
you just finish I
paired up with macro again no fisherman
let's try this okay I do not mind
this structure where's that night headed
take out my Jeep on LightSquared Bishop
why I want to make sure he could play an
active role long diagonal
let's stop d4 okay let's put my bishop
here I'm anticipating this break and I
want to have this pawn covered
conveniently let's start with this thing
keeping my king in the centre is good
not sure what that room is really about
how about hmm tough to say what I should
be doing here
tie for h4 maybe just walking right into
pins let's try this the rook is pinned
okay I don't want that file to open up
I'm not playing this well okay my knight
has this square let's get there oh boy
Queen takes pawn no don't do it
hope just man can I survive extra scary
holy cow
um
I cut the clue
ah
you
yes I love what I win like that
sometimes just sometimes that pond
everybody knows that pond was going to
turn into clean and be an animal he was
going to be an animal pac-man mode on
Red Bull he was going to eat all my
opponents pawns and I was going to win
Queen and King versus King oh sorry I
got loud there intense man it's an
intense game it's an intense game ha I
just tried to move Knight g8 to f6 there
you see that you goof your knight is on
e 7 oh man this is an intense game an
intense game look at these halls I love
them I love them which one I can't even
there's so many beautiful options I just
don't know where to go
let's hit the night and still stay in
the rook about that
oh maybe we break down dark squares and
stuff in a hide behind my pond
um
out of this pin somebody tell me I need
to get out of this pin oh they could
take my night I thought I was being
clever man I'm still in this pin how do
I get out
stop it oh man
okay can I take my rip on the rook rook
takes pawn rook takes pawn
and so
this one well where's the back rank mate
are there any back rank mates I get a
mate for second
on man
you
oh I'm doing a time
oh man
I was loving that game so much and then
I ended up in a pen it took out all my
took away all my time oh man I was
having too much fun talking about it
chest being an intense game shut up and
play man shut up and play it's not any
news man everybody knows it's an intense
game quit saying that and get on with
playing ah man what an awful game to
lose awful ah man I blame lag on that
one I think there was lag lags fault
let's hang on to that Bishop
go here go here you love that square
you're going to love that square
okay pins pins tournament is over by the
way it's long over more pins my nights
hanging I don't know what you think I
need time out I need to go into timeout
where's the timeout oh man I guess here
oh man this night this night is just so
dangerous I'm going to end up in a fork
or that look at this technique look at
this technique unbelievable
I'm going to lose on time again can
blame the lag oh my god oh I have to
stop playing I had to stop playing I
gonna make a Mista mate
oh my god they missed an eight I quit I
quit
Oh dad that game right there
I need I need to go into timeout I need
to go into timeout ah I just I won this
game but I should have lost this game I
should have won I should have lost and
then I won I don't know that's my best
description of that one in the end where
I finished fifth
61 Wow surprisingly close to even
seconds no one is catching 61 now 61 32
31 30 28 mm okay good I am if I won that
one yeah that one that I lost I would
have I want to got maybe SEC I would
have got podium land ah man
okay intense is always alright to the
130 of you good games off I can't
playing another one I got out whoo hey
you time out
you